with the decreasing water levels at lake
mead boulder harbor boat ramp is now
closed
madison kimbrough spoke to some boaters
they're really concerned for
the low water levels and now this new
closure she joins us live
right near the marina madison
yeah brian for these long time boaters
driving around on the water today was
not
easy and especially for the most popular
boat ramp that's now going to be closed
their concern
is that the other ramps will get too
overpopulated to use
getting through that channel it's just
super low narrow
so it's going to be super mindful with
lake mead water levels decreasing
lake officials have made the decision to
shut down boulder harbor
one of their main boat launching ramps
currently the channel depth is about two
and a half feet deep which is considered
too low to provide safe lake access
long time boaters feel like this is
going to cause a major delay in the
process but know once they're out on the
water
they need to take extra precaution it's
like the more they shut it down
then the more traffic it is the longer
people launch your boat longer to get
out
the rocks popping up out of the water
you gotta be cautious and take your time
we slowed down just kind of kept an eye
we got to the front bow and just kind of
looked
at the front and yeah just went super
slow the lake's level has dropped
significantly in the last 20 years and
it's expected to hit a new record low in
the next coming weeks
currently lake mead is below 1072 feet
and the last time it was above sea level
was back in 2000
we lived here since 1982 and i've
watched it drop
and to see it like this is pretty
devastating
chelsea kennedy with lake mead public
affairs says unlike the other ramps that
seem to close and reopen in a timely
manner
boulder harbor will remain closed until
further notice if lake levels come back
up and they fluctuate
over time then we'll look at opening it
back up but as of right now
probably through the better part of the
summer is going to be closed
as for ramps that are open on lake mead
hemingway harbor and
caulfield bay will be open for boat
access so boarders can look out for
those
reporting live from lake mead madison
kimbrough 8 news now